نشوان هي عمليات اقتحام اسرائيليه مستمره
بشكل يومي منذ السابع من اكتوبر وحتى هذا
اليوم في الضفه الغربيه وهذا اليوم يعني
تتركز الاقتحامات في مدن شمال الضفه
الغربيه خاصه مدن نابلس وطول كريم ومدينه
جنين في مدينه نابلس اقتحمتها قوات عسكريه
كثيره واليات انتشرت في عدد من احيائها
وبخاصه حي راس العين والقري وباب الساحه
وكذلك حي العطعوط
وسيرت قوات الاحتلال دورياتها في عدد من
هذه الاحياء وحاصرت عددا من منازل
المواطنين الفلسطينيين فيما نصبت حواجز
عسكريه في هذه الاحياء واوقفت شبانا
فلسطينيين ودققت في هوياتهم الشخصيه وحققت
مع بعضهم ميدانيا وكذلك توجهت قوه
اسرائيليه الى حي الى حي الى مخيم بلاطه
شرقي المدينه في داخل الحي نصبت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الحواجز وحاصرت
بنايات لمواطنين فلسطينيين وهناك دارت
ايضا رحى الاشتباكات مع مقاومين فلسطينيين
داخل مخيم بلاطه وكذلك في مدينه جينين
شمالي الضفه الغربيه اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بلده عرابه وسيرت دورياتها في
احياء هذه البلده وحاصرت بنايات وحققت مع
مواطنين فلسطينيين كما هدمت نصبا تذكاريا
لاح احد الشهداء الفلسطينيين وفي وقت سابق
دعني اقول اقتحمت قوات اسرائيليه ايضا
بلده سالم في مدينه نابلس ايضا وهناك دارت
ايضا مواجهات مع شبان فلسطينيين وكما نصبت
ايضا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حواجز
عسكريه داخل هذه البلده واوقفت مركبات
الفلسطينيين وفتشته وكذلك دققت في
هوياتهم الشخصيه فيما شهدت بلده قفين ايضا
في مدينه طول كارم شمالي الضفه الغربيه
اقتحاما اسرائيليا واسعا من عده محاور
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انتشرت قوات
راجله وكذلك اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه داخل
هذه البلده واطلقت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قنابل الغاز السام باتجاه حشود
لمواطنين فلسطينيين واتجاه المنازل ايضا
كما اطلقت قنابل الغاز المسين للدموع
باتجاه المواطنين الفلسطينيين وفي اوقات
سابقه اقتحمت قوات اسرائيليه ايضا بلده
بيتف في نابلس وا اداره ايضا هناك مواجهات
مع فلسطينيين واعتقلت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ثلاثه شبان فيما شهدت مدينه
بيت لحم وخاصه بعض قرى المدينه عمليه
اقتحام من قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايه
في والتي اشتبكت مع مواطنين فلسطينيين
واطلقت ايضا قنابل الغاز المسيل للدموع
باتجاههم التصعيد الاسرائيلي مستمر في
الضفه الغربيه بشكل يومي في في كافه المدن
والقرى والمخيمات من جنوب الضفه الغربيه
ووسط الضفه الغربيه وكذلك مدن شمال الضفه
الغربيه وتعتقل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بشكل يومي عدد كبير من المواطنين
الفلسطينيين بلغت حالات الاعتقال منذ
السابع من اكتوبر وحتى هذا اليوم نحو
6500 حاله اعتقال في الضفه الغربيه ومدينه
القدس وهو رقم قياسي في فتره زمنيه لا تلا
تتجاوز اربعه شهور هذه وكذلك قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تنشر عددا كبيرا من
الحواجز العسكريه في مدن الضفه الغربيه
وخاصه بين مدن الضفه الغربيه وتحاول فصل
الجنوب عن الشمال والوسط ايضا و وهذا يسبب
يعني
حاله يعني تعيق حاله السفر وتنقلات
المواطنين الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه
خاصه ما بين المدن انفسها وما بين
المخيمات
والمدن المركزيه في الضفه الغربيه بشكل
ملاحظ وواسع وهذه الحواجز العسكريه من
ضمنها حواجز عسكريه ثابته وهناك حواجز
عسكريه التي تسمى الحواجز العسكريه
الطياره ايضا داخل بعض الكره وهي حواجز
عسكريه مفاجئه تقطع
اواصر السفر بين بين القرى والمدن في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله